[Music]
with my own way and I made it I'm your
favorite reference baby call me at your
so
inside tectonic moves I'm in shul like
the fibrillator no style can't relate
I'll always be the
one drop down yeah put the camera flash
on so St
baby te is are gone Dr down yeah looking
like an ion
we yeah yeah 360 then you're in the
mirror do you like what you see when
you're in the mirror you're just looking
at me fing everywhere I'm so
jul when you're in the party that be 666
with the Princess Street I'm everywhere
I'm so J
[Music]
up
up that City still SLS the vi
internationally recognize that set the
go is my design and it's stuck in your
mind Legacy is undebated you going jump
if F made it if you love it if you hate
it I don't care what you think
drop down yeah the cam FL on so
styish baby is all gone drop down yeah
looking like an
icon yeah yeah 360 when you're in the
you see when you're in the Mir you're
just looking at me everywhere I'm so
jul when you're in the party that be 666
with the princess stre I'm everywhere
I'm so
jul open
up open
up open up
[Music]
ah hey friends I hope you enjoyed that
awesome flow session down in downtown DC
and if you're interested in picking up a
set of those pop and flow poy that I was
using in the video you can do that over
at flow toys by using the promo code
drexfactor
08224 once again that is drexfactor
08224 that will get you 10% off your
order and uh on anything else in the
store as well so go check that out thank
you so much to flow toys for sponsoring
this video and speaking of thank yous uh
big thanks go out to the Friends of the
channel that is big thanks go to dark
monk flow fests flow toys uh pyro Tera
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and a special thanks to the non-
business friend of the channel That is
Becca Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission here um and finally uh big
thanks after to go out to uh my
wonderful supporters on patreon without
whom none of the videos on this channel
would be possible in particular I'd love
to give a shout out to my flow patrons
who are listed on screen right now thank
you y'all Rock and if you out there
watching uh are not currently supporters
but you'd like to become supporters you
can do that by heading on over to my
patreon at patreon.com drexfactor and
signing up there you can find an awesome
array of rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and Flow to
the whole wide world so go check that
out please and thank you and if you are
interested in checking out more of my
flow sessions you happen to dig this one
you want to see me moving with the prop
more I will go ahead and include a uh
link to a playlist of those videos down
in the description as well as up on
screen thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow yourselves
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care peace